no dai a girarsi quale lo shift o non
c'è mai stato e lo scivolo come spinti
sono e pietro ma come ma come dietro a
pietro tu sei come me è uguale alle
amoci prepariamoci allora a noi non
dobbiamo far capire a pietro quello che
stiamo facendo che lui si sente che
trova meno melon testa per favore
ovviamente gioco corretto e non di
ascolto tranquilli diciamo le robe tipo
andiamo in quel posto dove l'altro
giorno io ho pensato di andare senza
dietro stiamo andando a me sto cacasotto
nome so no no no no io sofferente ai
polmoni ma sapevo che ci abbia skirring
bella non lo so che ciò che sta ancora
più stava con lei perché sei stanca che
con voi ma io ho messo la carica mentre
sport ormai c'e l'altra notizia qua
guarda c'è la traccia qui la mia non
corre più è morta a deborah lo re di me
la cosa ma tu sei vicino una batteria
sei bravo no io dire che stamattina ha
dubbi metterò di me io sono parlate che
non capisco nulla
ciao deve doveri rete allora entriamo
qui arriva a pietrelcina passa da me ma
era necessario no non lo era per niente
con la vedova vino sentito vedo come
basket roma cioè ceco conto ma che fuori
spicchio ce l'abbiamo davanti ma del
sito di seo sono va bene se c'è una cosa
da baseball serve di che cosa c ce lo
devi sparare da questa crisi a palazzo
ciro deve fare cambi ragazze non più
agitate ma se viene qua una carneficina
a mirko loro visto che la rai ha ammesso
batteria ma anche di aviaria e non cela
le chiavi non ce lo diciamo solo
baseball dobbiamo tra sole chiavi regali
un fatto tutto ma la mia non corre cioè
un po paraplegica sono stupido sono
entrato nella trappola monaco è ciccio
dopo aver oggi sono mille euro milano 29
facciamo un sorriso sotto la macchina i
casi si no
ma non ci sono ne vuoi difendere ma non
uscire col presidente cia pistacchio
vado matto 6 apistico vediamo guardateci
17 sparma inserimento non so paura
perché sono mancati perso non è qui da
una pista fosse così sarebbe un caso che
sono lo frimaire mi lasci fare
si no pietro manna ragazzi io sono
sposato come cominciato a votare
e vabbè ma non sapeva massaggi james si
può ammazzare al casinò non lo puoi fare
adesso
ragazzi io sto cercando le chiavi da due
ore non esistono cioè veramente l'avrei
già trovato guardare l'altro mi spiegate
dove sei
chi è questa macchina è questa in
macchina ora sarà finito ma è partita la
macchina la macchina statua cosa fa
cerchio e salì sulla macchina come
eccoci qui ne trovano un mega gas acqua
c'è questa qua tizia la macchina sono
fermate testa la macchina e troiani
ciccio malattia aiuto bravo aspetta e
spera
questa dieta mento che sta dietro
se questo si è fermati lo la mano a me
16 m 6 micetta fermate questo staff a
tutto il retromarcia non si è fermato
dove sta andando tutto ancora andando
vuole venire a salvarti ci credo ma
l'acqua con acqua marina dove l'inter
ora medievale prete non vogliamo più ed
è sempre stato il mio preferito tale
risalì sulla macchina io non riesco
neanche a scendere perché potevamo
termine
io ci sto provando ci sto provando ma se
quello non si ferma il mio giocatore non
corre rito
vai adesso è tramortito pietro noi
salvate mia vita mi aspettano
minchia che botta e dove è andato via
non mi corre figlie la casa deserto
d'acqua vacchino fermi che chiacchio
fate fate c'è salibra non mi capisci a
me cosa ho problemi e dall'altra parte
cicciano all'alba roma devi seguito
dall'altra parte era scomodo vi fa
venire la novità sulla sinistra dai
party no regala questo conseguita fatemi
di suicidi poco perché più invece
volesse un maestra guidare che ho capito
la prima la testa c'è stato capito non
sa neanche luigina guarda guarda se
ilieva continuando a limare da un'altra
parte è normale ma veramente visitato la
mattina week mai fatto e viscovo solo
bello ma è rarissima sta roba perché tu
sparato no perché non tanto un peccato
sì lo sapevo
ecco questo estremo e varie che sta
guida stava che lanciava verso la
madonna
ti giuro poi per fare ma che stai a fa
questo per me troppo anche di quella
vacca hai rotto il cazzo
dietro questa lama girati
adesso ma batte stupido va dai dai
datemi una mano con foreste voglio bene
io non posso fare niente non ho neanche
la chiesa di san macario dice chi è che
ha sempre odiato vorrei rinascere dietro
in questo momento bravo pietra e uccidi
lui che io veramente non ne posso più di
sta gente noi accendo stamattina pia
ciccio non ci pesa non ci crederà mente
magari al e ciccio vado io non sapete
fare niente non sapete fare un cazzo
guido io che gli altri non sono capaci
faccio io ciari ciccio cosa che l'atomo
rete con marrazzo è arrivato è certo la
sgommata ma sono fatto anche prima
quando mi ha guardato gesù esco di qua
si esce illesa installate aspetta che
noi passiamo in quel punto perché un
malato però stavo così guarda spetta ad
aosta corre più giusta più allora io
conosco una via di casa che quest'anno
vista anche in cappuccetto rosso sta qua
val colla per andata a nonna facendo
giro guarda ho visto a casa mia a casa
eccolo lì acceso come rotti i [ __ ]
magliana scherzano a cagare lo investono
nel peso amodio no investito ciccio ma
che è successo si è pagato non pagato
dell'albero lega non pagato a ballarò è
capito oddio se morto è dire se molli e
ciccio cosa che lei che cosa vi ha
investito cima dove stile jazz con il
vestito ciccio salvo è possibile ho
sbagliato ma quello là se metti
mezz'asta perché un fetente maledetto
fai schifo vai via
hai rotto papà st madonna perché ha
fatto lui gesù tra tutti votato a uscì
lui come l'albero fallo tu quella fra
scala creator che ha fatto anche
allegato 30 e 27 secondi
ciao mia che schifo
da parte loro aiuto e invece si è cioè
la distrazione cura di garri 13 ai 18 4
3 2 1
ce l'ho fatta a me mi ha detto tu morto
è già morto bellissimo e stata una roba
incredibile questa mappa diversa legale
allora dobbiamo non dobbiamo fargli
capire chiunque sia jason a meno che non
sia io nel caso fate non capì bene
stiamo andando
perché se non ha un seno che tipo viene
o no ma pedro è però non so io e pietro
di euro e non ci è piaciuto non si è
fatto gesù
l'ultima volta è stato il casinò recavo
la che forte dell'altra ma io che vorrei
proprio capire dove siete
non lo so io sono in una casetta mattei
in vicino tipo un cimitero normale
cimitero esatto femori noi la angle e
ciccioli ha già capito ha capito il
trucco a me la porta che io sia morta
chiudi non ci sei
chiamati pazzo ma gli appaia guarda io
mi vendicherò di pietro io dimmi se
devono essere stata vista nella mia vita
ci siamo ridotti a questo salvati pietro
arriva mamma mia
ok velino di essere morto si teneva è
stata una scena che mi sono proprio
google ma c'è però adesso è ora di
andare bene ma che è componibile via ma
non sono io rimbambito ma che poi la
rete voglio dire cosa aspettano e volevo
vedere mia scena di pietro non hai
capito non è niente di che
allora io sto di non poco le chiavi del
valore ecco le sei tu hai capito è messo
pure chiara sasso personaggio aia
ha tirato una botta gotica copresc e
botti play secco marino fabbrichiamo è
proceduti fatto prima ma è ancora
lontano ecco la messa non è vero lo
giuro ho che succede fassino occhio
troppo nella trappola
ma ecco che resta una botta tempo la
donna allora io volevo io ci ho provato
una forte si va mai a vieni qua ha detto
non puoi uccidere uno così capello che
il legale è stata veramente figo quanto
mai mancato mamma mia era un bel gioco
questo è quando vuoi ma porca miseria ma
per forza per forza
[Musica]
ma